I was checking out the David Pakman show
reddit discussion forum this morning at
david pakman.com slash read it a lot of
interest in next week's upcoming
interview with host of the reuben report
dave rubin you will be able to
participate in that interview if you go
to our reddit discussion forum because
we've got a sticky to post at the top of
the page where I am soliciting questions
for dave rubin this is a special thing
that we're doing next Tuesday instead of
the regular broadcast show where we do 7
stories and a short interview we will be
having the full hour with dave rubin and
the bonus show on tuesday will contain
sort of our regular political stories
over over 90 questions so far submitted
for dave rubin at david pakman.com slash
reddit and I encourage you to check that
out also on our reddit discussion forum
an interesting Reuters article
indicating that according to the French
president Emmanuel macron Donald Trump
might reverse his decision on the Paris
climate Accord that is being reported by
Reuters and there's a discussion about
that on our reddit discussion forum that
you can check out an interesting
question posed by a user on reddit named
an issue that you've moved to the right
on and the user that posted this
suggested some areas in which he has
moved to the right over time and it has
led to a pretty interesting discussion
about how politics can change over time
and different issues on which maybe some
of our viewers sensitivities have
changed over time also on our reddit
discussion forum a link to a five thirty
eight.com article about when you can
trust a story that uses unnamed sources
and these unnamed or anonymous sources
and they are actually two different
things
unnamed meaning sources known to the
journalist but not named in the article
anonymous sources can sometimes be
actually sources whose identity is
unknown even to the journalist although
the terms are sometimes used
interchangeably that has become a pretty
big focus even of the Trump
administration
Donald Trump taking a position on media
should not be able to use anonymous
sources or whatever totally clueless and
and uninformed position but it's become
quite a topic of discussion and that's a
really interesting discussion that's
taking place among some in our audience
and lastly we did on the bonus show
earlier this week we audited producer
Pat's claim that he has one to two cups
of coffee a day because I said Pat I've
seen that gigantic thermos that you
bring in there's no way that there's
only one or two cups of coffee there so
we actually measured out on the bonus
show how many cups of coffee is Pat
drinking per day I won't spoil the
results for you
but one of our viewers asking how many
ounces of coffee are in a cup of freedom
of the press brand brew six or eight
which of course is one of the to freedom
of the press and progressive wake up
call are the two roasts of David Pakman
show coffee that are available at david
pakman.com slash gear and a lot of
people the endless controversies around
coffee and producer pat are really
starting to we're I think on his
approval rating although I don't believe
it will ultimately be a scandal that
takes him down I'm pretty confident in
that join our discussion forum at david
pakman.com slash read it a lot going on
there on nearly 4,000 of our viewers and
listeners now participating